Speaker 1: . We have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine two. David P. You can call
anytime you want. Here's a caller. This is sad.
This actually again, this we're not joking here.
This caller feels that his mom is now
officially off the deep end based on the
bumper stickers she now has put on her vehicle.
Speaker 5: Oh, David! It finally happens. Yeah,
my mom is pretty anti. Biden posted a picture
today of her car shows a new bumper sticker.
So startled member of the. F J B LGB
Speaker 1: community right now, that's not LGBT.
Remember, F J B is f Joe Biden and LGB is let's
go Brandon, which is. Supposed to allude to
RF Joe Biden, it's the same thing. The number
of emails and voicemails I get from people who
sound almost despondent like that guy because
a parrot or even sometimes a significant other
has gone completely off the deep end into these
non-thinking movements. It's actually sad. It's
genuinely sad how many people call and say, I
just don't know what to do anymore? Do I cut this
person off? There are sometimes parents will call
and say, my parents are off the deep end, and I'm
wondering if I need to cut them off from my kids.
In other words, the grandkids of the parents,
because I don't, I don't want to or I don't want
'em hearing this stuff. I don't want them around
really, really difficult. And with Thanksgiving
coming up now just a couple of weeks away,
I anticipate I'm going to keep getting the calls
with concerns about Thanksgiving gatherings,
as we do every year. But it seems particularly
bad this year because not only is it
do I want my kids around the anti-vaccine, in some
cases, statements from parents, cousin, uncle,
whoever do I want my kids around unvaccinated
people? Do I want to be around unvaccinated people
at Thanksgiving? So it's going to it's going to
be an interesting one. But to put it lightly,
we have a fantastic bonus show planned for you
today. We will talk about Singapore is now saying
if you were unvaccinated by choice, not because
of a medical reason. If you're unvaccinated by
choice, you're not going to get free health care
anymore if you have COVID and you're unvaccinated
by choice. We're not covering your care
conglomerate is splitting into three companies.
Why and what are they? We will tell you. And
Congress is now getting, I guess you could say,
more aggressive with carmakers and saying you have
to figure out a way to stop drunk driving. We have
to fix this at the car technology level. Is it the
right approach? And what tools do carmakers have
that they might use to stop drunk driving? All of
those stories and more on today's bonus show. You
can sign up at Join Pacman Dot Com and we will
see you then or tomorrow if you're not in that.